good morning heck it's tuesday i was
struck by something the sierra leone and
footballer mustafa bundu recently said
to a reporter he said we want people to
see the positives in our country
football-wise but also in other areas of
life so that when you talk about sierra
leone you aren't just mentioning war or
ebola and over the years of working to
support a stronger health care system in
sierra leone we've focused a lot on the
real and important injustices that led
to the country's impoverishment but
today i want to tell you a joyful story
a soccer story okay quick background so
every four years all the best men's
national teams in africa play each other
in the african cup of nations which
sierra leone had not qualified for in 26
years the lyon stars as they are known
are currently ranked number 108 in the
fifa national rankings but after a
couple big results in qualifying by june
of 2021 they found themselves one win
away from making the african cup of
nations they just needed to beat benin
the hero of that game would be kai
kamara who began his career playing for
a team in freetown before coming to the
us as a refugee when he was 16 where he
played college soccer and then had a
long and distinguished career in mls kai
kamara had long dreamed of representing
sierra leone at the african cup of
nations but by the time of the benin
game he was 36 years old he knew this
was his last chance and he came through
the leone stars one of somewhat
controversial penalty and kai kamara
scored and back home the celebrations
erupted around the country because
sierra leone had qualified for its first
major tournament in 26 years just making
the tournament was a huge accomplishment
as the national anthem played before
their first game last week kai kamara
and several of his teammates had tears
in their eyes nobody thought they had a
chance in the tournament itself like
most experts ranked sierra leone 23rd or
24th out of the 24 competing nations and
in the group stages they had to play two
of the best teams in africa algeria and
cote d'ivoire both those countries have
11 players who play their professional
football in europe's top leagues sierra
leone has none if you're not into
football it can be hard to understand
just how huge of an underdog sierra
leone is in this tournament but think of
it this way their starting goalkeeper 22
year old mohammed kamara plays for east
end lions a professional team based in
freetown in his first game in the
african cup of nations he faced shots
from riyad mahrez who just won the
premier league with manchester city and
yet muhammad kamara stopped those shots
in fact he stopped every shot in that
game which sierra leone tied 0-0
never has a tie felt so much like a win
after the game when he was handed the
player of the match trophy muhammad
kamara burst into tears and all around
sierra leone people poured into the
streets honking horns waving flags and
singing the anthem four days later
against cote d'ivoire muhammad kamara
saved a penalty using the brilliant and
somewhat unconventional strategy of
standing behind the goal line before the
ball was kicked but even so in the last
minute of the game they were down 2-1
and it seemed quite hopeless and in my
head i was already writing this video
about how they lost the game but they
did their country proud but wait no the
opposing keeper made an error and sierra
leonean striker alhaji kamara somehow
recovered from a stumble and dinked the
ball over a defender and scored and it
was 2-2 a second miraculous draw in as
many games again the celebrations
reverberated throughout the entire
country celebrating the result yes but
also celebrating the heart of their
players their tenacity their belief this
is a country that is growing and growing
together on thursday the leone stars
will play equatorial guinea and if they
can somehow win sierra leone will
complete the impossible qualifying for
the knockout stages of the african cup
of nations the world will be watching
and hopefully celebrating with the
people of sierra leone hank i'll see you
on friday we're gonna go out there we're
gonna put our hearts on the field we're
gonna put our buddies on the line for
sarah young